okay long story short I dated this girl
uh from 20 to 27 okay and
uh long again long story short the
reason why that ended was an Asian
mother got in the way right so anyway
fast forward I'm 37 now seven years
later uh I got divorced two months ago
and haven't talked to that seven-year
relationship girl in 10
years and we just recently
reconnected
and we we both found out like she had no
idea that her mom was doing all the
crazy [__] behind her back and that
broke us up and all that stuff so we we
we reconnect 10 years later and uh we
find out that the mom was the
issue and so we've been spending maybe
about the last month and a half together
and it's been
fantastic and her Notch count is still
under five
is this a question along the lines of is
it a good idea for me to do this Rich
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah
well plates is not an issue uh I got
plates the second my wife left or my
ex-wife why did you guys break maybe
maybe let's start with the conditions
under which you guys broke up okay so
seven years in um her mom I me my phone
down for a sec her mom started doing
this everywhere we went like so we would
go for dinner and she'd like go under
the table and like do this to me I'm
like it got so insufferable that I
couldn't even uh like I didn't want to
go to their house anymore because
basically her mom was pressuring me
being like yo you got to marry my
daughter it's been seven years I'm like
how old was your daughter seven years
ago same age as me exactly we we're um
we're not high school sweethearts but we
were in the same grade and we met After
High School H so how old were you guys
27 at the time yeah 27 okay so she's
saying yeah it's about time [__] get
off the Pod fire a ring okay yeah the
mom was saying all that so anyway um
then I started talking so I the I
thought that the girl was telling her
mom to do that to me to get me to hurry
my [__] up so then I started talking
about marriage and then I said I'm like
of course I will this girl is [__]
awesome right um she's still [__]
awesome which is another weird thing so
she started to
feel what's the word press Ed into
marriage which I didn't understand I'm
like wait a minute I thought you were
telling your mom to do the the Ring
Thing everywhere I went and all this yet
right so anyway um she had just finished
high school and she's like I don't know
what I want I'm like what are you
talking about you don't know what you
want I we've been together for seven
years I thought you wanted to get
married she's like I don't know if I
want to get married I'm like what the
[__] oh sorry sorry not going to swear
didn't you just get out of a marriage
you just got
divorced yeah two months ago yeah
totally different scenario and situation
any kids with her
no are you planning on having
kids I would like to have kids yeah okay
so then you have to vet this chick as
wife stock as mother's stock and you've
already been with her and broken up with
her you know they say never go out to
the curb and rumage through the garbage
you know know you've taken the garbage
out you let the you've put it out there
for the garbage man to go get it right
so why would you go back out to the curb
and start rumaging through the
garbage right when the only reason this
is a point of like um gray area is she
didn't know her mom was doing
that and then we found out 10 years
later that her mom was doing is that
like really something that would that
would break up a couple that's solid you
know Mom going under the table put a
ring on her finger sort of thing like
encouraging you to marry her
daughter like there's got to be
something Gooding there like why didn't
like is there a real reason why you guys
broke up cuz aside from just doing this
[__] right like I have like I have my
girlfriend's family from time to time
you know especially like the nieces and
nephew there sometimes drop like some
sort of comment I'm like look kid you
don't want me to get into marriage and
stuff like that so you know and then
I'll just send them back to their mom or
dad because they know exactly what I'm
gonna
say right right so I mean like you're
gonna get this right like if you're a
top shelf guy and you're dealing with a
woman and you're seeing her family her
family wants you to to lock her down and
get married to her because it is safe it
is protective it's good for her low risk
High reward especially if you're a
successful guy of course they're going
to tell you to go get married but you
just have to you know if it's not
something that you want to do or that or
doesn't serve you or it's not aligned
with your life goals then you don't do
it just say that's not
me right so why did you guys break up
because it wasn't the
mom she the theas reason why we broke up
at the time um she said she didn't know
if she wanted to get married right then
and
there and then her mom was pressuring me
to get married so then I said well and
then she said I want to go on a break
for a bit to see what I wanted to do
with my life okay there it is I want to
go on a break right I she was also I was
also her first as well okay so you're
also her first so she racked up five
more notches after that or four more
whatever it happens to be
so are you starting to see what the
break part of it is right the uh you
were you were her only source of
intimacy she was 27 she didn't really
want to get married her mom wanted her
to get married because she saw you as a
good option and she wanted to explore
options that's why she went on a break
so she went out now and she explored her
options she shared her body with four
other men and now she's coming back and
she's saying hey the grass wasn't green
around the other side of the fence what
are you doing it 100% was not either she
regrets it for sure like all those guys
were totally [__] sorry totally
useless so yeah but I mean like here's
the thing though like she left you she
abandoned you a commitment to you
because I'm assuming she's like hey
where do we stand you know I'd like to
claim said that yet no no no before I
mean like you guys were dating yeah and
then and then she went and abandoned
that to go and play the field to go and
sew some Wild Oats to figure out if
there was some greener grass somewhere
else and she didn't find it for me
personally if a chick breaks up with me
and wants to run around and then comes
back after she's done running around
saying hey what are you doing let's get
together I won't even give her the time
of
day interesting yeah I don't want to be
anybody's second third fourth fifth
Choice [__]
that to be fair chapter three in my book
genuine burning desire have you read it
yes yeah um it's all there that's the re
reread it ReRe know hey hang on hang on
the the thing is that breakup I was
completely blue pilled and I was obese
and I was a total piece of what garbage
got back then got it right so you
weren't as as appealing as a man as what
you are today no the the breakup was the
best thing that could have happened
money driv your car I'm guessing moved
on bought something nicer to live in I'm
guessing yeah okay well yeah you've
gotten better your smv is gone
up right but but you'll never forget
that she left you to go explore options
now that I've pointed that out to you
that's what she did she broke up you to
go and explore options
100% okay that's it's not what I wanted
to hear but I think that's what I needed
to hear yeah it is what it is uh like
she's not I mean look I don't know how
fat you were I don't know how poor you
were I don't know what your status was
back then clearly it wasn't as good as
it is today or as good as you feel it to
be today and it's understandable that a
woman will always look at other options
if you're not the best that she can get
if she gets up in the morning and looks
at you and says I can do better than
this guy she's gonna go and try to do
better than this guy she went out she
found that she didn't while she was
doing that you worked on your [__]
you've leveled up and now she's like oh
well there's that guy over there I
remember from seven years ago we had a
good time and he really liked me maybe I
can convince him to be with me now that
he's got his [__] together and is all
jacked and Saucy and stuff
right right that's for me it's a noo
right so I mean you will you will you
will never look at a woman the same way
when you realize that she left you to go
and bang other guys she left you to go
share her body with with with four other
men before she came back and said you
know what this guy did some work I think
I'm going to go back to him a great
woman which are few and far between
would have stuck with
you but again you know you were a blue
pilled beta too right so right you know
you're you're you're taking ownership
for your part of it but just know that's
why she's coming back and that's what
happened it wasn't it wasn't her mom so
let's not blame her mom for
this gotcha okay if anything her mom
would have probably had her marry you
but she didn't want that she wanted to
go and check out some other
options Goa would you keep her as a
plate then it's very difficult to keep a
woman as a plate that's from your past
that you were enthusiastic about she was
potentially enthusiastic about you
because then feelings get involved and
if you're just going to keep her at arms
length at some point she's she's either
going to disconnect from you and say
look I can't do this or you know she's
gonna say something like you know frame
Chasers I love you and you know where's
this going and I can't do this if we're
not together right it's like even
friends with benefits it'll run its
course because usually somebody catches
feelings you know for the other person
or they find out that they're seeing
other people and then jealousy kicks in
sort of stuff so you can try
um I don't like that's why they say
never go back to an ex right because the
circumstances in which you rekindle when
you see why you broke up and it's
usually women leaving men like 80% of
the time women and long-term
relationships it's not generally men
leaving women it actually takes a lot
for a guy to leave a woman so if you
ever hear stories about a chick where
guys leave them constantly like if
you're out on a date and she's like well
Bill left me and then seven years later
Chad left me and then you know eight
years later Kevin from sales left me
it's like okay there's a common
denominator here there's something wrong
with this chick she's probably crazy
right so just as a side note you see
what I'm saying though but yeah my
advice is don't do it I bet that you can
do better than
her I know I can I know the thing is I
have a I don't want to take too much
your time but man when I date younger
girls they they haven't even seen like
Seinfeld like it's like or
like there's such a gap of like like
they didn't grow up with like cassette
tapes and like super stokers I know it's
just oh my god dude you you invite them
into your world you don't have to go
into their world you don't give a [__]
what it is that they do with Snapchat or
whatever it happens to be if you're if
you're successful if you're competent if
you're seasoned older guy and you like
younger women because you're attracted
to them and you generally find a woman
that's younger than you and I wouldn't
go too young like I wouldn't go 20 or 30
years younger like right usually seven
to 15 years is pretty reasonable right
you can go 15 years 20 years up to you
but you you invite them to do [__] with
you like you're a captivating guy you've
got a social network uh people probably
find you interesting you invite them
into your world you don't go into their
stupid [__] right that's how you deal
with a younger women basically but yeah
um just to sort of you know before you
go my good friend Steph said that you
know he's always said this and I've used
this phrase you know from time to time
the door is unlocked going out but it's
locked coming back in if a chick leaves
if she wants to leave you if she wants
to explore other options you know as she
explicitly stated to you then that door
is locked when she comes back it's get
[__] Goa that's just my take on it but
that's that's how I view the world right
now and not everybody's going to see it
that way right like you're going to go
and do what you think is right for you
but at least contemplate
that sounds good all right okay I really
appreciate that my man all right boss
take care okay thank you I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out